on behalf of Abbott I'd like to welcome
everyone to the habit molecular dinner
speaking program here in San Francisco
we have a distinguished speaker today
dr. Ashish Kamat from MD Anderson Cancer
Center dr. Kumada is a tenured professor
of Urology and the director of urologic
oncology fellowship at MD Anderson
Cancer Center and a graduate of the AOA
Leadership Program dr. Kermit's
expertise is in multidisciplinary
management of urologic cancers with an
emphasis on bladder and prostate cancer
or conspireing therapies middlee
invasive techniques and orthotopic
bladder substitution while he is a busy
surgeon he maintains an active research
portfolio to improve the care of
patients dr. comets efforts are directed
towards identifying predictors of
response to therapy especially
immunotherapy as a first step towards
personalized cancer therapeutics a major
focus of his laboratory research is to
develop novel treatments for bladder
cancer and identify resistance
mechanisms and ways to overcome them he
has he serves as a project P ion the MD
Anderson Cancer Center GU bladder spoor
dr. Hamad has authored over 200
publications editorials and book
chapters in prestigious journals he is
listed in Who's Who in medicine and best
doctors in America and has won the
compassionate doctor award from patient
groups he is an exceptional educator
nominated twice for the Robert M
Chamberlain distinguished mentor award
and has been invited as a visiting
professor to several universities across
the world
dr. cabanas co-president the
International bladder cancer Network
chair of the bladder cancer think-tank
in 2015 and chair of the bladder cancer
task force for SITC
and actively participates in various
global urologic efforts and serves on
the board of regional and national
societies of urology please welcome dr.
come on thank you very much so thank you
for that kind introduction
what I'm going to cover today
essentially is predicting response to
interval in vino therapy and it's mainly
BCG but really we look forward to being
able to predict response to any
universal therapy the
umino therapy for bladder cancer as you
know is really in a exploding field
right now here are some disclosure
slides this is the your vision slide
with the intended use and limitations on
here I wanted to start out a little bit
since you know diagnostics and looking
at psychology really involves visual
cues so take a look at this slide and
tell me or don't tell me yet but keep to
yourself how many legs do you think this
elephant has okay and I'll show the
slide later but just try to tell
yourself how many legs you think this
elephant has and then some of you may
have seen this slide before it sort of
really emphasizes a visual issue that we
all face when you're looking at and
colors and perception but look at square
a and square B and again keep this to
yourself because I'll bring this up
again later which square do you think is
actually darker between a and B okay so
just a little too visual questions for
you and then when we kind of start out
with little case example so cases are
always important because they help us
understand how what we're talking about
actually affects patients in the real
world so this is a 52 year old male
usual presenting symptoms of micro
hematuria otherwise healthy was a smoker
was evaluated with the usual imaging the
CT urogram in a cystoscopy was found to
have about a centimeter and a half high
grade tumor on the left lateral wall
this was appropriately resected found a
VT one hi great then resected again and
there was no residual disease this
patient who started an intrical BCG
therapy which is the standard of care
for these kind of patients and underwent
maintenance at three months after
negative negative cystoscopy the patient
then had a six month surveillance of
Tosca P which was negative cytology at
that point was negative but the fish was
positive because the sitarski was clear
the urologist decided to just continue
with the BCG the patient had a
nine-month evaluation with cystoscopy
cytology at this point was negative as
it was at the six month at the 12 month
the cytology was atypical the urologist
obtained
vision test it was positive the patient
underwent evaluations estas cap again
was negative and urologist appropriately
looked in the bladder looked in the
ureters did the appropriate imaging and
because they couldn't find anything said
well the positive fishes because there's
a lot of inflammation in the bladder
from BCG and stop the BCG for this
patient because they were concerned that
the BCG was inducing abnormal test
results the patient went on having
surveillance estas capiz essentially was
rendered or on paper was put down as no
evidence of disease
cytology wasn't done either because the
psychologies were negative in the past
and fish was positive so the urologist
felt well there's no point doing any
more marker studies and we sort of know
now that cytology doesn't perform well
so it's understandable that someone
wouldn't want to get psychology but when
this patient went on at 24 months the
two-year mark had actually grossly
mature again so Frank bleeding in the
urine cytology at this point was
positive in the Eurovision fish was
again also positive and the urologist
decided well rather than look in the
bladder and do all the work up again let
me send the patient to me at this point
for blue light cystoscopy enhances Tosca
P which the urologist didn't have in his
our office so of course I saw the
patient reviewed the pathology he had a
conversation with the patient repeated
imaging which is negative at this point
and the plan was to take the patient to
the operating room to look in the
bladder do blue light evaluation do
biopsies of the bladder prostate etc but
as soon as you look into the urethra I
don't know if you can see this on the
slide or on the screen but there's
clearly tumor in the prostatic urethra
and we resected this tumor in the
prostatic urethra and it ended up being
high-grade bladder cancer not only
involving the mucosa of the prostatic
urethra but actually invading into the
stroma of the prostate t4 disease which
is bad so the patient underwent
chemotherapy needed a radical cystectomy
underwent a radical cystectomy the
pathology was t1 in the bladder after
chemo so this is not you know someone
that's responded dramatically to
chemotherapy but it did get down stage
however when
patience nodes were evaluated there were
47 lymph nodes removed but six lymph
nodes were positive and that's really
bad disease per se we counseled the
patient in adjuvant chemotherapy because
at that point there was no immunotherapy
as far as the systemic immunotherapy
agents available patient decided to
observe and not go on any actual
treatment you can see the CT scan six
months later widespread metastatic
disease all of the liver and this young
patient unfortunately succumbed to his
disease so it's a real good reminder as
to how we need to pay attention to
active surveillance in these patients
pay attention to the markers that were
obtaining and actually listen to what
the markers trying to tell us and I'll
just not ignore it and and and not pay
attention to what it's saying so I
talked about BCG and that's what this
patient got and and I'll talk about BCG
as far as the predicting the response is
concerned because it is really the most
common treatment that we have for
bladder cancer patients nowadays you
heard a lot about immunotherapy you see
it in the news you see it on the Wall
Street Journal because it is come back
into vogue so to speak for bladder
cancer but really if you think about it
we've had BCG for more than four decades
when it comes to management of patients
with bladder cancer it is the original
cancer immunotherapy globally there's
about 1.2 million doses of BCG
administered to bladder cancer patients
every year but as of today we still do
not know how to predict which patients
are going to respond to BCG and which
patients are not going to respond and as
you saw from the case example if a
patient doesn't respond to BCG and
enough time elapses this patient
actually gets really aggressive invasive
disease that can metastasize and take
the life of our patient so before I go
into predicting response to BCG I want
to touch upon a few myths when it comes
to BCG therapy and the reason these
myths exist is because we've had BCG for
40 years but but multiple markers looked
at to try and predict who's gonna
respond not respond but as you can
imagine when there's 40 years of data
that's that's been out there people
forget the basics so this is sort of
like going over some of the basics
of intra vesicle BCG when it comes to
bladder cancer so the biggest myth that
you often hear from roll gist is that
BCG doesn't actually reduce progression
of disease it only reduces recurrence
rates this is just not true and this is
an old slide it's from Richard Sylvester
who runs most of the trials for the ER
TC is their lead biostatistician and
it's a busy slide but you can see the
Green Line is to the left of the screen
as you're looking at it that pretty much
means that these trials showed a benefit
of BCG when it came to reducing
progression of disease when amendments
BCG was used and that's the other point
that I want to make is that BCG does
reduce progression rates not just
reduces recurrence rates but it reduces
progression only when maintenance
therapy is used again this is the graph
that shows that the fact that you can
see the blocks to the left of the
midline there suggest that BCG reduces
progression but only when maintenance
therapy is used the second myth is that
okay fine I'm gonna use maintenance BCG
but I don't know what the maintenance
schedule is or that there's no real
optimal maintenance schedule that has
been identified and again this is just
not true it's something that's been
propagated because people have looked at
all their studies that don't actually
show a benefit with maintenance therapy
this is the classic swab protocol that
showed that maintenance BCG reduces
recurrences and progression from bladder
cancer and the top line is maintenance
therapy and the bottom two are induction
alone but what I mean by that is that
induction BCG essentially is six weeks
of BCG so patients get BCG once a week
for six weeks and that's considered
induction BCG the SWOG protocol or the
down lamp protocol or the standard
protocol nowadays for maintenance
therapy you get the six weeks of
induction BCG and then get three weekly
main pointers so once a week for three
weeks
at month three months six and every six
months thereafter for three years and
that's the maintenance therapy that
actually shows a benefit to maintenance
therapy with BCG from reducing
recurrences and progression the reason a
lot of people say Minton
it doesn't work is because they're
referring to trial such as these this is
where one installation of BCG was given
every three months it was studied as
maintenance therapy but this maintenance
therapy didn't actually help the
patients over induction alone this is
another regiment that was studied and
these are large cancer centers that have
looked at this and this is giving one
installation of BCG every month and
again that is maintenance therapy but
this maintenance doesn't actually work
it has to be done once a week for three
weeks as a swathed protocol and the most
common mistake that we as urologist used
to make is give a patient six weeks of
BCG and then just wait six months give
another six weeks of BCG and call that
maintenance therapy but again as you can
see here from a study that was done in
Spain by Jean Paulo that maintenance BCG
doesn't actually work any better than
induction alone so even patients are
told by the urologist that maintenance
therapy doesn't work they're not wrong
the wrong type of maintenance doesn't
work but if you do the maintenance right
clearly maintenance therapy works and
there's actually scientific evidence to
back this up this is a study that was
done in 1999 looking at cytokines in the
urine it looked and to see why the
patients developed the immune response
you can see here at the induction BCG
when someone is immunotherapy naive you
get a rise in the cytokines from week
one two three four or five all the way
up to six but when the patients already
received BCG if they get one two and
three
there are installations of BCG their
immune systems getting ramped up but if
you give them too much BCG it's an
immunotherapy you're actually
suppressing the immune system so that's
where the three weeks of maintenance
therapy comes in and it's also important
when it comes to looking at patients
today that are being deemed to be BCG
failures you know patients with
carcinoma in situ are looked at in the
bladder at three months and someone
calls them a failure they go on clinical
trials and the clinical trial shows some
benefit ten fifteen twenty percent and
that drug that's being studies looked at
as a success but if you look at the
actual timing of recurrence of patients
with carcinoma in situ with BCG this is
again adopted from Don lime study back
in 2000 these are patients with
carcinoma
titoo that were randomized into two arms
one that got mean wounds PCG one that
got induction VCG alone and is expected
after an initial induction course of BCG
at the three-month mark the C our rates
complete response rates are about 55 58
% now in the arm that went on
observation so no more maintenance BCG
the CR went up just with time because
the immune therapy requires some time to
work it went from 58% to 69% but look
what happens when you give these
patients maintenance BCG the CR goes
from 55% to 84% so imagine if patients
and this happens even today patients at
the three-month mark without getting
maintenance BCG are told well you've had
induction BCG you've failed her therapy
let's try an experimental drug that drug
is put in and we know you know some
drugs have been approved with a 10%
response rate you go from 55 to 65
percent with that drug and it's
considered a response but just giving
more BCG would take that patient from
55% all the way up to 84% so it's
important to recognize the importance of
doing adequate maintenance immunotherapy
and you know 64 percent of the so-called
failures would have been salvaged if
they just had appropriate BCG therapy
per se another myth is that BCG only
works for high risk disease it doesn't
work for low grade patients that is just
not true and people should know this
it's the ER TC through a 9/11 study that
clearly showed that even patients that
have low-grade disease and this is a
population where cytology just doesn't
work and when you're trying to you know
monitor these patients psychology is
very ineffective and that's why some
urologist don't like to surveil these
patients with psychology which is
understandable but BCG in this
population works so it's a low-grade
disease but it's intermediate risk
category because these patients are
recurring and this is actually one
population in this study where BCG was
shown to reduce deaths so there's a
misconception that low-grade bladder
cancer is not going to kill anybody
again not true it can't kill our
patients and if you use BCG you can
actually reduce the deaths from bladder
cancer in these patients per se now I
talked a little about our risk
stratification like
gets a little confusing so I just wanted
to put up the slide here a low risk
bladder cancer is any patient that has a
single first-time low-grade T a tumor a
high-risk patient is anybody that has t1
disease or a high-grade cancer that's
clearly easy to understand the
intermediate risk category that I talked
about earlier is patients that don't
fall into the low risk or the high risk
category so essentially anybody that has
a T a low-grade tumor that's been
recurrent multiple or large is an
intermediate risk patient and that's a
simplified definition that the
International bladder cancer group that
I lead has put forward has been adopted
now if you're looking at risk
stratification within the intermediate
risk category of patients there are ways
to do that we've proposed several risk
factors the number of tumors the size of
the tumors how often the tumor occurs
and and the frequent recurrences and
again this is available to help risk
stratify which patients should go on
again treated such as low risk patients
which patients are getting treated such
as the high risk and which patients fall
into the true intermediate risk category
the last sort of myth that I want to
touch upon a little bit again is that
not all patients can tolerate a full
course of BCG and this is really
important because urologist will often
just stop BCG at a arbitrary time point
claiming that the patient can finish the
course of BCG this was true back in the
1990s when the studies were started
because we weren't smart enough to
actually recognize little things that we
can do to help our patients using
aspirin for example or using
anti-spasmodics or just stretching out
the interval of their BCG therapy so
back in when the trials were done the
swauk protocol for example only 16% of
patients actually finished a full
three-year course of BCG today however
when you look at multiple trials that
have been performed the EO RTC through a
962 for example the IPD survey that the
International bladder cancer group
performed you can see that less than 10%
of patients 5% in the IPD study had to
stop BCG so going from where 84% of
patients had to stop the BCG before they
reached three years
to less than 10% having to stop BCG is
clearly because urologist have gotten
smarter they know how to manage
side-effects there are more drugs
available for us to use and patient have
gotten a little bit more smart as well
so they are motivated to go on to get
the full course of BCG and do everything
they can in order to improve their
results with the immunotherapy now the
fifth myth really is what the main
subject of this talk is is how do we
predict response to BCG so it's sort of
a tongue-in-cheek a myth the fact that
we can't predict response to BCG we can
but we don't really have very robust
tools unless you know exactly what to
use so when it comes to predicting
response to BCG what do we have today in
2018 well we have the standard clinical
pathologic features the the patient's
gender the grade the stage of tumor the
presents our options of CIS how deep the
tumor is in the lamina propria whether
is a variant histology the reetou our
data parameter intrical therapy and the
fish status the Eurovision fish pattern
of these patients per se so let me touch
upon these a little briefly so again the
Spanish group put together a curator
score this is Spanish organization the
Europeans have done the same as well we
don't have that but the aua in the u.s
but there are groups putting together
these sort of nomograms you can clearly
see that you know you can give these
patients different scores based on their
gender the number of tumors the grade
stage this is just common things that we
as urologist use and it can predict who
is going to respond as far as recurrence
patterns are concerned and who's going
to respond as far as progression is
concerned this is something that's not
new it just been quantified by these
several studies we - our data is
something that's very important so we
have patients that have a tumor that's
been resected and then we take him back
to the or and do another resection to
make sure we cleared out all the tumor
from the bladder as you can see here
when it comes to predicting response
during traversal therapy patients have
had t1 high grade disease on the initial
resection and then again have t1 a great
disease on the repeat resection
have only a nine
percent response to the intravascular P
if they don't have T when I grade the
response rate is 82% so the reetou our
data does help us know who's gonna
respond who's not gonna respond to BCG
therapy the presence of variant
histology and this for example is micro
papular bladder cancer this is a
corridor patients that were referred to
us that had micro property bladder
cancer t1 high-grade got BCG and you can
clearly see here that the large majority
89% recurred but more impressively 67%
of these patients progressed and the
progress rapidly so they went from
non-invasive disease to invasive
metastatic disease all at a median time
point of 8 months simply by virtue of
having variant histology so nowadays we
know that variant histology predicts for
a poor response to BCG therapy now
looking at different tumor and
biomarkers has obviously been in vogue
for for many years people about that p53
when it comes to bladder tumors they've
looked at correlating this with response
and there been studies that showed that
p53 status does correlate with response
to BCG but they've been just as many
studies suggesting that it doesn't
correlate with response to BCG the same
problem with any of the other markers
that you look at when you're looking at
tumor cells and the reason for this
really is that BCG is an immune therapy
right so it works by stimulating the
host immune response and hence manifest
the anti-tumor activity so if you're
only looking at tumor characteristics
it's not going to show you the entire
picture when it comes to BCG response
and that's why people have looked at
antibody response to BCG this is a study
that was actually performed many years
ago in 1981 where they looked at the
antibody response after patients to BCG
therapy and showed that clearly if a
patient has appropriate antibodies in
the blood they have a better response to
BCG when it comes to their bladder
cancer and again you know using this
data people have looked at cytokines
that looked at aisle to aisle eight
individual cytokines and shown sort of a
separation you can see these curves
separate a little bit but you're really
not going to tell your patient to have a
right
suspectin based on a slight separation
of their curves because this really
clinically isn't that relevant so we put
forward a trial trying to look at
prospective markers of response to BCG
therapy this is a trial that was
registered with the NCI it was supported
by the spore program at MD Anderson and
the hypothesis really was twofold number
one
can we look at cytokines which looked
helped us look at the immune response of
these patients to BCG and can we look at
the fish patterns in order to look at
the cytogenetic lis abnormal cells that
these patients have in their bladder and
the hypotheses was that the cytokines
will help us predict response and the
fish patterns will also help us predict
response
so I'll bottom-line this the cytokine
response did allow us to predict
response to patients and differentiate
responders from non responders the
responders essentially have higher
levels of cytokine response to BCG in
the bladder the magnitude of induction
of the cytokines is higher in patients
that I've got response to BCG but it's a
complex interplay of the cytokines in
the bladder and that's why the previous
studies really didn't show a large
separation I just want to show one
example this is aisle 8 induction in the
urine of patients you can see here that
you get a p-value that is statistically
significant it's P less than zero zero
four one but there is a fair amount of
overlap in these boxes and there's
clearly patients who have a recurrence
but still have a high cytokine level and
that's because again the immune system
is fairly complex so when you look at
this it's not a clear linear coloration
the higher the amount of BCG induced
violate the better it is up to a certain
point but beyond that you're actually
overwhelming the immune system and
you're suppressing the response to
interpersonal immunotherapy so because
of that it's a very complex kind of
nomogram that that is required to look
at the different cytokines in these
patients and we published this before
it's looking at il-2 six eight eighteen
one are a trail and gamma and
tnf-alpha and you can put this in a
point system but it does allow us with a
fair amount of accuracy to predict the
response of these patients to inter
vesicle therapy and we call it the supra
des a the cytokine predictors of
response to intravascular P it's
currently being validated in a large
multicenter study here in the US and
also overseas and the area under the
curve is 0.85 so it's about 85% accurate
which is almost too good to be true so
it definitely needs to be validated
coming to the fish patterns of these
patients again this was the hypothesis
of the trial that the fish patterns will
help us predict the response to and
traversable BCG you all know that your
vision fish was f15 10k cleared in 2001
and then approved in 2005 diagnosis in
symptomatic patients with hematuria it's
based on molecular probes that detect
certain genetic alterations in the urine
cells that are shed and it looks at the
four probes on chromosome 3 7 17 and the
9 P deletion and this is just a
graphical representation of what it
looks like under the microscope you guys
doesn't know this sort better than I do
and the scoring I put this slide up here
many to emphasize one point often times
you'll get reports that say well you
know 500 slides were looked but cells
were looked at in an automated fashion
and four were picked up or we looked at
two cells and then pick up anything and
we call it negative so it's important
for people to recognize that you have to
select the morphologically abnormal
cells and this could be from size of
these cells if the cells are irregular
they have abnormal nappy staining they
shouldn't be overlapping because you
have to be able to identify these
clusters and if there are no abnormal
cells visible then of course you want to
scan all the cells but if you have these
abnormal cells minimum analyses of 25
cells needs to be performed and then the
patient is deemed to be fish positive as
approved by the FDA if four or more
cells have
gain of at least two or three 7:17 or
the more twelve or more cells have a
deletion of nine p21 that's the p16
signal and this is important because
oftentimes we see patients that are
referred with fish test that's been
reported out as a positive negative but
it's not been done the appropriate
manner and that may have significance
and that's been studied by our group and
others but it's not a classic fish
positive or negative so when we design
this trial we went with the classic fish
positive or negative based on the
approved FDA indication and this is
again it in a nutshell so you can see we
did fish on these patients at baseline
with it fish on these patients at six
weeks after resection of the tumor at
three months and six months and at every
time point you can see that the fish
positive patients had a worse outcome
compared to fish negative patients so at
baseline you can see a separation it's
statistically significant as early as
six weeks after resection of the tumor
fish positive patients did worse than
first negative patients same thing at
three months and same thing at six
months and as you go longer and longer
out from the initial resection the
curves do separate and this is important
because it allows us to actually adjust
not only our risk stratification of
these patients when we're looking than
in a clinical scenario but it also helps
us kind of adjust the surveillance
pattern of these patients and I know we
do this and and in the community my
colleagues do this as well if a patient
is fish negative you feel a little bit
more at ease and the patients on the
bottom are ease at stretching out the
interval if they're positive fish
positive obviously we work it up
but if you don't find a tumor in the
bottle you're still got that heightened
sense that there's something going on
with this patient we should look in the
prostatic urethra we should look
elsewhere in the upper tracts we should
maybe see them more often than just you
know every 90 days per se when this data
is useful but again what I want to
emphasize even more is that the pattern
of these patients when it comes to fish
positivity so we get the fish for
example at baseline it's negative at six
weeks it's negative we can get different
combinations of
positive negative and let me just
highlight this a patient that's baseline
fish negative and again fish negative at
six weeks has a 12-month recurrence
percentage of barely thirteen percent
and a zero percent progression rate all
the way up to two years whereas if a
patient is negative at baseline but
converts to positive as early as six
weeks these patients have almost a 60
percent recurrence rate at two years and
40 percent progression so you go from
zero percent progression all the up to
40 percent progression if a patient is
is negative and converts a positive and
clearly there's something going on in
the bladder of these patients because
they were cleared by the TR BT despite
getting BCG there are fish positive and
they have a large potential for not only
recurrence which is bad but progression
which can kill these patients so it's
clearly something that we use and can
use nowadays when it comes to monitoring
these patients but again that's
important from a clinical perspective
what's even more exciting in a way and
if we have used these and other people
are starting to use these as well is to
design clinical trials so if you look at
the three-month data that I showed you
earlier you saw the separation between
the fish positive and negative this is
putting it in in numerical terms so if a
patient at three months after a section
of put the tumor and starting BCG is
fish positive they have a 57 percent
recurrence rate at two years compared to
eight percent of their fish negative and
they have a 50 percent progression rate
within two years compared to three
percent of their first negative so as
early as three months after resection of
tumor you have this clear separation 50
plus percent compared to less than ten
percent of patients and why is that
important well today when we have a
patient that gets on BCG therapy but
fails the standard of care for these
patients is to take out their plier
that's in all the guidelines that is the
standard of care but clearly patients
don't want to have their bladder taken
out when they have non-invasive disease
so what happens you put them on a
clinical trial but because of the
Parador arm is a radical cystectomy we
can't really randomized to taking out
someone's bladder versus not taking out
someone's bladder so the FDA has agreed
based on you know our discussions with
them to allow us to do single arm
studies so what that means the patient
of fails BCG goes on a study with a
single arm with no control group and
that's actually been allowed to be
called a randomized phase three study by
the FDA it's just what they do so
patients go on drug they fail BCG and
they go on a single arm study but how do
you make sense of these studies there's
no control arm you don't know what
you're comparing against so we in
International bladder cancer group and
the FDA proposed certain numbers for
people to use and we've come up with
these numbers and this is based on
historical data if you have CIS you
should have a CR of 50% at six months
which would be durable at 12 months to
30% and 25% at 18 months and if it's
pepper disease again you don't look at
CR as early as six months but then you
look at the recurrence rate of 30% at
one year and 25% 18 months but again
even though we have these numbers the
point I'm trying to make is it's a
single arm study right so you may have a
drug that meets these benchmarks but if
you had an appropriate control arm you
wouldn't really be able to see a
difference if these patients had less
risk factors and that's where the fish
positively comes in so the trial design
that we and others have proposed is you
have a patient that gets induction BCG
such as six weeks of BCG and that the
first evaluation is fish positive or
negative so the patient is fish negative
clearly they have a good outcome you
don't have to worry about a thing you
continue on with the BCG and they're
doing well if their fish positive
however they are at a very high risk of
recurrence 57% progression 50% but they
haven't recurred yet so they don't
actually have a tumor that you can see
in the bladder but you know by 2 years
they're gonna have a high recurrence on
progression rate so these are patients
and you can discuss a clinical trial you
can talk with the patient say well your
high risk of failure from BCG so we
have a clinical trial that we can
provide to you but the controller mr.
BCG so because here we have the ability
to randomized these patients to a novel
agent so BCG plus something and also
ethically continue on BCG because this
standard of care it will allow us to
move the field forward if this trial
design is adopted by more folks in just
a few universities that have looked at
this so this is trial design that we
have proposed and hasn't been adopted by
several groups including geo ASCO in
2013 so I'm going to summarize the talk
really we were asked by the European
Association to put forward a nice review
of ways in which we can predict response
to intravascular I repeat today as you
can see we came up with different tables
the definitely useful before treatment
was the clinical parameters that I told
you about the age grade stage etc of the
tumor and then during and after
treatment was the fish pattern cytologic
examination of the said shared cells
this was categorized by the expert panel
as being definitely useful when it came
to probably useful before treatment was
biomarkers genetic profiling of these
tumors it was a separate assay the
cytokine assay that I talked about and
of course emerging strategies are the
molecular subtypes of the tumors genetic
profiling that that you've been hearing
about but today as of 2018 what do we
have available it's the patient's
clinical pathological parameters
age stage grade of the tumor and the
fish pattern so it's well recognized by
experts that using the fish pattern of
these patients does allow us to be able
to actually predict who's going to
respond to treatment who is not going to
respond to treatment and that's been
recognized by several agencies including
the American neurological Association
that have put in the guidelines and
these are back from 2016 that clearly
states that in a patient with non-muscle
invasive bladder cancer a clinician may
use biomarkers and the erosion fish is
listed here to assess the response to
intervention
BCG therapy and then also to educate
equivocal psychology there's data that's
going to be presented at this a UA that
will expand on our trial and and urge
you to go in and visit and see the
presentation which is going to be
tomorrow actually there's other data
that's coming out from Europe and other
larger studies but Mike O'Donnell for
example that have looked at similar
questions and and should be published
fairly soon going back to these pictures
that I put forward between a and B which
one do you think is actually darker well
they're the same color it's a visual
perception right I mean because you have
the green column they're the cones and
rods in your eye are not seeing the
difference between a and B and unless
you have something connecting it a looks
darker and we looks darker to 95% of the
population that's 5% I was hoping none
of those 5% would be here and they're
not that can actually tell the
difference with the green cone there and
it's usually the people that are green
red colorblind that can actually say
that a and B are the same color and then
this question your how many legs that
this elephant have four or five oh the
answer here I I don't know thank you